welcome to the first episode on the
baseline data ml and AI quest this quest
of all introductory levels self-paced
labs is intended for the complete
beginner in Google cloud you'll get your
first touch experiences with a subset of
the Google cloud services that provide
tools for working with big and small
data machine learning and artificial
intelligence services in Google cloud
after you're done with all the labs in
the quest you'll get this badge to
recognize your achievement
you can add the badge to your social
media accounts and resume pull it others
know about your new skills the way this
show works is you'll watch a short video
like this one or I'll be introducing you
to a lab on quick labs and give you a
quick overview of what you'll learn I'll
also point you to additional resources
where you can find more information
about each topic once you're done
watching the episode you can head on
over to quick labs and do the lab you
can watch all the videos and then do all
the labs or you can work on the labs and
then pop over to the videos to find
additional resources this is your quest
and you can follow it in the best way
that suits you you don't even need to do
the labs in order I'm excited to get
started so let's move on to our next
episode and first lab in the quest
bigquery QuickStart using the web user
interface